the gist is brought to you by
castlevania lords of Shadow 2 I've been
hearing for a while now that the gist is
a pretty random sure sir for today's
episode I thought why not take random
and run with it as we talk about
real-world uses for Titan falls Titans
not only that but a lot of today's
suggestions are crowd-sourced so here
are the five big reasons why you guys
wanted a gigantic metal best friend
alright so no surprise here one of the
main things you guys wanted out of your
new gigantic metal buddy was a better
way to commute even though Titans on
typically fast you guys were keen to get
around town on one of the metal beasties
as soon as humanly possible although it
isn't just about getting from one place
to another you wanted to arrive in style
and I totally get that I mean I've had
my eye on the Toyota gt86 for a good
while but when I stuck that up against a
Titan it's a pretty easy coal to go for
the latter I give it less than a month
before it if he is on top gear is the
hot new product or at least I'd
envisioned a bunch of increasingly we
had tests to see how it stacks up to the
competition I sort of take
responsibility for this one since I
think my last just episode encouraged
this way of thinking but apparently one
of you guys wants to use your brand new
Titan to pick up chicks I'm assuming you
mean literally pick up chicks like off
the ground but then again I suppose a
person with a gigantic mechanical best
friend would have a certain Janice a qua
so maybe it would help you out in the
dating scene on the topic of the literal
definition though I'd suggest picking up
stuff in general would be pretty damn
handy you couldn't exactly get him in
the grocery store but he sure could help
carry all the bags not to mention
changing the tires on the car you no
longer need and shifting furniture or
breaking said furniture accidentally
another you guys had for your Titans in
the real world was reaching high places
for his bees off rooftops and cookies
down from the top shelf type of thing
I'm sure Scylla wouldn't have been half
as pissed at Walt for throwing that
pizza on the roof if she'd had a Titan
handy to help get it down although while
this suggestion started as what seemed
to be you getting your taller buddy to
help you out with a little problem it
seemed to quickly devolve into
straight-up manual labor where you had
your Titan hypothetically cleaning your
gutters and painting your house in no
time and that takes us pretty cleanly
down to the second most popular use for
a Titan in the real world
getting it to do stuff you don't want to
do any company our first world problems
and general laziness in one fell swoop
is the fact that most of us basically
just disregard the fact that he's a
monstrous and all-powerful
Titan and actually just wants somebody
to do stuff for us
pardon the fairly grim Association but I
can't help but wonder if this is how
slavery got going a bunch of the things
you guys wanted your Titans to take the
reins on included standing in line at
the post office picking up drive-through
and taking spiders outside to that I
probably add holding elevators rendering
the stairs in my house unnecessary
letting the cat in and hitting the light
switch off for me when I forgotten about
it and am already in bed now while I
don't disagree that all of those things
would be super useful I can't help but
think that maybe just maybe we aren't
quite taking advantage of our gun-toting
almost impenetrable powerhouses at the
end of the day though most of us did
realize just what our pet Titans would
be capable of and funnily enough tended
to radiate towards great good or great
evil those who went for the former were
all set to pressure world leaders into
giving to the poor ending war and curing
cancer not quite sure how you were going
to achieve that last one with giant
metal hands and a bevy of missiles but
points for imagination and then there
was the other half of you that went
straight for world domination
when I asked on Twitter what you do if
it was only you who got your hands on
one of Titan balls epic max a whole lot
of responses indicated the flattening of
foes punching out of high school bullies
and taking all the world can offer for
oan so what'll it be for your well
domination or world salvation or do you
have a better idea altogether for your
new titan best friend you can let me
know in the comments down below or on my
Twitter where I'm at just MacDonnell be
sure to also let me know if there's
something you'd like to see on the show
and I'll catch again next week
you